بمعجزة مطلقة ، تمكنت بعض هؤلاء
الفتيات من الفرار في تلك
الليلة المرعبة ، لكن حتى بالنسبة لهن ،
لم ينته هذا الكابوس بعد ،
وافقت إحداهن على التحدث إلينا ، لكنها طلبت
ألا نتعرف عليها بأي شكل من الأشكال.
لا تعطي اسمها
لمنزل عائلتها أي شيء يمكن أن يجلبوه
إلى ما تخشاه أكثر من
عودة الخاطفين لأنك ترى
أوه في المرتبة الثالثة سكوت ما نوع السيارات التي
كان المجد الحقيقي لها واحدة على واحدة
بالتأكيد سبع شاحنات نعم  وكان هذا
في تمام الساعة العاشرة ليلاً AJ ، ففعل
ذلك جعلك تشعر أنهم جاؤوا
للحصول على الفتيات ، أنا هذا
عندما علمت أنهم قد جاءوا لاختطافك ،
نعم قالوا إنني أستطيع  دخلت إلى هذا المستوى
المتواضع ، كنا بشرًا لكنني أغني ،
وسأنسدل ، لقد كان ذلك شجاعًا حقًا منك ،
وهنا نستمتع عندما تكون
مخطئًا في دوبش ، لقد ركضت في الأدغال
، وماذا حدث بعد ذلك ، مرحبًا
، نحن هدفنا ممكن  تصف الرجال
الذين جاءوا وأخذوك كيف
نظروا  مثل ما إذا
كانوا يرتدون ملابس مدنية أم أنك تمارس تأثيرًا عسكريًا على ما يرتدونه جيدًا ، لا أعلم
أنني لا أعرف أكثر من ذلك ، لكن ما هو
لباسهم وما الذي يرتدونه ،
يبدو أنهم شعبويون هل بدوا وكأنهم
جنود هناك أمل حقًا  إذا كنت
تشعر بالخوف ، فأنت لا تريد التحدث
عما يبدو عليه الأمر ، فلا بأس ،
أفهم أنني آسف